there are Fitness chips out there but
our next guest has mental fitness tips
that are going to help you now and into
the new year you're running around the
kids are home and starting to get bored
so why don't you take a breather our
next guest agrees and has some great
tips she is resilience Coast Deidre
Perry and her boys Nathan and Evan are
joining us welcome you guys thank you I
love that we're talking about mental
Fitness because it's just so important a
lot of us going into the new year think
I'm going to work on my body I'm getting
better this is the one this is the place
that we really need the help right yeah
that's right how do we get into that
right frame of mind going into the new
year
so first of all it's it's having
awareness of how you're feeling in the
moment and the best way to do that is to
use your breath
now when you say use your breath the
actual breathing exercises that you can
teach us and show us how to do that yeah
and you you've actually helped the boys
uh really learn and to embrace this yeah
we actually we do it every single day
okay can you guys show me yeah yeah
let's see let's take a look so um it's
really easy we do heart focused
breathing and so all we do is we start
to take an inhale through the nose
and actually through the mouth
we just focus our attention in the
center of our heart and you imagine that
your breath is flowing in and flowing
out of the center of your heart or chest
you just continue to breathe in more
slowly and more deeply than usual and
you create a rhythm in through the nose
and not through the mouth it really you
can feel like your heart rate coming
down you can feel your blood's getting
that oxygen that it needs and and how
have you used it as a mom to to be a
better parent
so it literally every single day so when
they're having an argument like they
actually can do it on their own now so
I'm like you guys let's breathe or they
will say we need to breathe so they
breathe together we breathe together as
a family so when we do that our our
Brazilians
um well I mean we get resilient because
we start to regulate our nervous system
so we have that pause we just take that
moment and have that breath and then
sometimes like well how do you guys want
to feel because maybe they're you know
having a situation like why wouldn't it
feel you know um you know grateful or I
want to feel you know appreciative so we
tap into whatever that is so we just
take a moment and breathe and then add
that onto it as well do you guys notice
that it helps you to to calm down in
certain situations it helps a lot it
helps us so like we're not arguing no
one gets hurt as much as usual that's so
great I mean look at how just centered
they are now if people this is you have
this method that's attitude breathing is
that different and so attitude breathing
is where it's like okay how am I feeling
right now maybe I'm feeling um nervous
so okay how do I want to feel I want to
feel courageous okay so you take a
moment while you're doing hard focused
breathing then you just imagine that
feeling you don't think you feel that
feeling of Courage until you're
breathing in that feeling of Courage do
you put yourself in that position where
your mind is there and your body will
follow it seems like yeah it's such a
great method um if you want more
information I'm sure viewers would love
more information how do they reach out
how do they get information from you I
have a website it's Deidre perry.com die
draperry.com and I actually have a
holiday special that's ending on the
31st where I just I offer a couple of
special holiday packages to help people
get resilience during the holidays oh
that's wonderful so definitely check it
out boys you guys are amazing so well
babe I want to do what they're doing